hello everyone i'm chris crycho i'm a
senior staff software engineer at
linkedin working on the road to type
script for ember taking things from
where we've been good to great
today we're going to talk a little bit
about how we got here a whole bunch
about where here is and then just a
little bit at the end about where we're
going from here
now since we're at ember conf you might
expect that this is a talk for ember
developers and of course it is and for
ember typescript developers specifically
and of course it is but it's also a talk
for ember javascript developers and in
fact it's also a talk for non-ember
typescript and javascript developers
because many of the things we've been
working on are applicable not just a
typescript but also to javascript and
not just to ember but to the broader
ecosystem
so let's jump in
how did we get here
there are three broad eras to ember's
history with typescript
the before times the early days and
recent history
the before times run from 2011 through
about 2015.
ember itself appeared in 2011 typescript
appeared in 2012 and they ran in
parallel without much overlap other than
collaborating on the start of the
decorators proposal all the way back in
2014
until a couple key things happened in
2015.
ember itself started using typescript
and typescript put out support for jsx
in the form of tsx
typed templates which really for the
first time gave front-end web developers
the ability to have end-to-end types
for their javascript code really
powerful and at the same time ember
began investing in the internal
implementation of its rendering library
for its template layer the glimmer vm
in typescript
that brings us to the transitionary
period the early days
in 2016 near the end of the year
typescript put out a couple key features
kiev and map types if you're curious
which unblocked the ability to actually
represent ember's classic approach to
building things
in typescript it was a little janky but
we could do it prior to that we hadn't
been able to and so in 2017 a group of
us got together and we made ember cli
typescript work and we built out type
definitions on definitely typed the at
types packages you're all familiar with
and after that we settled down into a
seti state over 2018 and 2019.
things were
fine
they were actually decent you could get
things done
but there were some gaps and so in the
intervening years since then recent
history we've started trying to address
them
one of those gaps was semantic
versioning we're going to spend a bunch
of time on this so for now i'll just let
it be said that starting in 2019
linkedin was really researching hard how
can we
solve the semantic versioning and
typescript problem by which i mean the
typescript team doesn't believe semver
makes sense for compilers because
literally every change you make breaks
somebody we don't actually agree with
that but it's a given in the ecosystem
and we can roll with it we spent a bunch
of time over a few years mike north
first and then me
actually getting a handle on how can we
solve those problems
then in 2020 and 2021 the good folks
over at salsify dan freeman and james
davis
did some hard work to say that
innovation that happened in tsx what if
we could do that in ember can we get
type aware templates
for ember and glimmer users and the
answer is yes the fruit of that research
was glint a tool which uses typescript
with ember templates and we'll see more
about that later
and then finally starting in early 2021
and running up through now
we've been working on official ember
typescript support
a lot of rfcs and that brings us to
today like like i said a lot of rfcs
there are
many things we've had to address to make
this viable
if i just tried to work through all of
these in order all of your eyes would
glaze over and you would tune out not
least because the order that we wrote
them in isn't necessarily the order that
makes the most sense it's just the order
it happened to get done so instead i'm
going to take them by chunk a couple on
philosophy one on the details of how
ember is going to apply that philosophy
a whole bunch on the changes to
authoring code we're making with an eye
to making things better for both
typescript users and javascript users
and then finally docs and you'll notice
there's a tbd there there's a reason for
that
let's start with philosophy
rfc 724 said
we're doing this we're going to make
ember have official typescript support
with the goal that it's a positive sum
outcome across the community and indeed
beyond ember
the how of that is some guardrails
number one we will never require
typescript you can think of this as the
we're not doing what angular did
guardrail and
it was a fine choice for angular to make
but we're not doing that we're making
typescript appear to javascript not
something that replaces javascript not
ever
as part of that we commit to doing the
work during our design processes to make
sure that
all our investments in typescript
actually actively improve the experience
for javascript users in the amber
ecosystem and we'll see a number of
concrete examples of this later
we need to make sure we keep our
stability guarantees which means we need
to figure out how semantic versioning
works
when dealing with typescript
we'll invest in specs like assember spec
and tools
integration in ci early warning about
breaking changes etc to make this
possible and we'll ship types natively
not from definitely tight
semantic versioning
we decided we needed to really think
hard about we took the insights that we
had developed at linkedin over the
preceding years and hammered them out
into rfc 730. among other things this
consisted of a very very deep dive into
typescript semantics because it turns
out that figuring out what a breaking
change is or isn't is hard when you have
to deal with
variants in type level mutable variables
when i first started researching this
there was literally nothing on the
internet about this at all and if you go
searching now
ember rfc 730 is one of the top hits
because this was original research we
needed to do to solve this problem
and we think and hope what we came up
with will be really useful across the
typescript community you're a node user
writing a node library or a dino user
writing a dino library or a svelte or
react library author this can work for
you
so what's the short version of it well
we've defined some policies for how you
handle upgrading typescript versions
including that you need to tell people
what types of versions you support
and
you need to test those to make sure that
you don't break things accidentally for
people
and then
we came up with some rules about how to
think about breaking changes and this
comes back to the old good advice about
api design be generous in what you
accept and conservative in what you
provide
but we formalized it
those support policies
as i said everybody needs to specify
what policy are you using and what
typescript versions do you support and
what constitutes your public api because
those are the things that have to not
break and there are two broad options
here the simple majors policy and the
rolling support window policy
simple majors is simple
if you drop support for an existing
typescript version
that's a breaking change for your
library that's it you can add support of
course but
you can't make people upgrade their
typescript version without it being a
breaking change under this policy and
this matches ecosystem norms around
things like node
when a node lts goes out of support and
we drop support for it most libraries
call that a breaking change
the other policy is a little more
complicated things aren't necessarily
breaking just because they drop a
previously supported typescript version
instead
long-term support releases whether you
have that formally like ember does or
it's just an informal thing that you
don't make breaking changes very often
need to make sure that they have
overlapping supported typescript
versions because this allows people to
ladder up that is they can always
upgrade to the latest supported
typescript version on your library
without having to upgrade your library
and vice versa once they're up to the
most recent version that the your old
library version supported then they can
upgrade to your new library version
without also changing typescript and
this is key because it means that no one
has to upgrade both at the same time
because those are the painful kinds of
upgrades
nothing is as bad as trying to upgrade a
library and having to upgrade five other
dependencies at the same time and trying
to figure out which one is causing all
the breakage internally for you that's
terrible this policy avoids that and
this matches the way foundation level
ecosystem packages again like ember
itself
treat things like node when a node
long-term support release goes out of
support
ember dropped support for it
the key here is that semantic versioning
is a socio-technical contract and i
could do a whole talk on this and
hopefully someday i will but the key is
that we keep our contract so whether
your contract is simple majors or
rolling support windows
you just have to keep it and then people
won't be broken by surprise and in fact
if you do them as we've suggested in
this rfc they won't be broken at all
here's how this works in practice ember
modifier is an ecosystem library in the
ember world using simple majors it's
currently at version 3.2 and if you look
at its readme this is what you'll see it
says we follow the current draft of the
semantic versioning for typescript types
rfc we support typescript versions 4.2
through 4.6 we also test against nightly
and we use a simple majors policy
our public api is everything not in a
private folder pretty simple
things are a little more complicated for
what we expect to be the case for ember
source
if we adopt the rolling support windows
and spoilers for a later slide we we're
doing that for ember
here's how it might work given that one
ember releases every six weeks and every
fourth release so roughly twice a year
is a long-term support release and
typescript releases once a quarter
we can imagine that ember starts
publishing types using this policy at
ember 4.8 and at that point it supports
typescript 4.6 and 4.7 now when ember
4.8 comes out typescript 4.8 will also
be out
but we don't have to support a
typescript version just because it
exists maybe there's a big performance
regression or a significant
bug in typescript 4.8 we don't support
it that's fine
as long as we keep the rest of our
contract so we go along through ember's
normal release cycle and typescript's
normal release cycle and whenever 4.10
rolls around typescript 4.9 is out and
ah this one this one works it solved
that bug in 4.8 so we add it to our
support matrix we also notice that it
has a nice new feature we would like to
use but
not yet because we still need to support
users back to 4.6
we get to typescript
4.5.0 release and the ember 4.12
long-term support release and hey we
have both of those now we could drop
support for typescript 4.6 here but
there's no point the new feature we want
is in typescript 4.9
and we can't require that yet so we
don't we just keep supporting what we
have
we keep rolling through the normal
release cycles by the time we get to
ember 4.14 typescript 5.1 is out things
are going nicely
we get to ember 4.16 another long-term
support candidate and here here's where
things get interesting
since ember 4.12 supported up through
typescript 5.0 we can go ahead and drop
things earlier than 4.9 and now we get
to start taking advantage of those fancy
new features we wanted
the key is
people could just upgrade while still on
number 4.12 to typescript 4.9 or 5.0 and
then they can separately upgrade to
ember 4.16 and go along their way no big
deal meanwhile we've also added support
for typescript 5.2 and the cycle
continues
the key about this again is that no one
ever has to upgrade both of those
dependencies at the same time
only one at a time it makes the upgrades
easier
but the other key to this is that it
lets ember keep moving forward or other
libraries doing the same thing we're not
stuck supporting typescript 4.6 only for
the entirety of ember 4's life cycle if
we'd done that for example in the ember
3 lifecycle we'd even stuck on
typescript 2.8 even though by the time
number three ended we were on typescript
4.2
we don't want that we want stability but
we don't want to get stuck we don't want
to stagnate this lets us solve that
going to the question of breaking
changes again though
we said that the rule is basically be
generous in what you accept and
conservative in what you provide and as
a consumer intuitively you can think of
this as the no new red squiggles rule if
i stick with
typescript versions that the library
supports and i follow the upgrade
cadence that the library itself
recommends i won't get new red squiggles
in my code from my library
maybe i will from typescript itself it
might catch bugs in my code as new
strictness settings appear but
fundamentally the library should absorb
those itself for its public api so that
i don't get broken by them
formally
well
as i alluded to earlier the devil's in
the details i've shown here the very
long very detailed outline of
december for
typescript
types rfc and it's long and it's it's
very complicated but it's also very
interesting if you're a library author i
recommend you take a look at it because
this will help you think about
the broad strokes but also the edge
cases you can find this at
semver-ts.org
it's a draft it's
1.0.0 beta 1. we still want your
feedback we think this is solid we've
gotten good feedback on it already but
if you try it out and you find something
come let us know we want this to be a
resource to the entire typescript
ecosystem
that takes us through our philosophy and
don't worry we'll move through the rest
of this a bit faster but i think it's
important to get the philosophy right if
we're going to do the rest of it right
for example when we get to the plan
it's a lot easier because our concrete
semver commitments can be spelled out
in terms of that policy
core libraries in the ember ecosystem
ember source cli and data will use the
rolling windows support policy most
other libraries will use simple majors
just like they do with node our breaking
changes policy is don't do breaking
changes except at a major like you would
expect
there's an important nuance around
additions that i want to call out though
and that is that we say an
ember
we only have to support the current
edition at a new major release ember
uses additions as a way to gather up a
bunch of incremental progress we've made
and collect it all and make sure it's
well documented and fits together things
can get kind of messy in the middle but
once we get to an addition point like we
did with octane and like we're planning
to do with polaris it all makes sense
again altogether fitting nicely
in
a major release
we can make breaking changes but in a
minor release we can't and additions are
always released in minor releases this
is a key part of how ember handles
versioning
so we can't say when we release an
edition our types only support that
edition but what we can do is when we
cut a new major we can say we only
support the current edition so
in the current world for example the
types we start publishing from ember are
going to have minimal fallback handling
for ember classic idioms
we only commit to actively really
supporting amber octane features and we
could do the same in the future it's an
escape hatch it's one i don't expect
we'll ever need other than the octane to
classic transition but if we do we have
it and it's a useful tool again semantic
versioning is a contract we just have to
keep up our ends of it
we're also going to make a point to
migrate everything from definitely typed
to
publishing from our own packages and
this is really really important for
being able to uphold that stability
story as well as to be able to do things
ember users are used to from member
for example if we want to backport bug
fixes we can't do that on definitely
typed but we can when we control the
types and we can do that by writing type
tests
similarly we're used to being able to
support alpha and beta and stable as
discrete things
we can do that if we control the types
using ecosystem wide tooling
that are not ember specific
we can't do that indefinitely typed so
this puts us in control of things that
are really important for our stability
story
we also are making communication updates
our rfc template now includes
how do we think about this from a
typescript point of view what do we have
to teach that's different there what are
the actual types same thing goes for
blog posts if we add a feature or
deprecate a feature in a way that only
affects typescript users we need to tell
people so that'll be become part of our
publishing process
and last but not least docs doc stock
stocks but we'll get to that
that's the plan
but to make it work we needed to make
some changes to the authoring experience
of writing typescript and javascript for
ember users
the first of these was first class
component templates rfc 779
the goal here is to make component
templates a first class peer to
javascript or typescript along with css
we can now use them side by side but
with a different set of tradeoffs than
jsx and tsx has
the goal here
is not to have html first or javascript
first
they're peers in modern web applications
as is css
so
we want to keep the benefits of
dedicated templating languages that we
can use actual native html syntax that
it's nice and declarative that we're not
mixing concerns
at the same time we can have the
benefits of local javascript we get to
use modules for scoping or name spacing
we get to refactor easily we get to
compose things nicely we can extract
local only components or helpers or
modifiers that's what i'm showing in
this example here and i'm not going to
walk through this in detail now because
i'm going to walk through it in detail
later
but
this is a big win for both typescript
and javascript users in terms of the
authoring experience and it's probably
the biggest change we've ever made to
authoring components in ember
i think it's going to be great i've been
using it a bunch on small things here
and there
and
it's really really good it feels like
the best parts of things like jsx and
the best parts of how ember's templating
story have worked historically
it's great
but for typescript users there's an
added benefit and
that is that glint our type aware
template system
doesn't have to reinvent the world
previous language servers for ember have
done really great work but they've had
to do that with heuristics what is this
component i have some guesses but i
don't necessarily actually know what is
this helper same deal
that's not true anymore glint can do one
thing and it's a hard thing but it's
just one thing and that is turn a
template into something that typescript
understands
and after that it can let typescript do
all the hard work go to definition
refactoring docs on hover
you name it typescript does that and
does it well we don't have to reinvent
that wheel
the other upshot here is that that works
for javascript users too because glint
is not a typescript specific tool as is
the case with most things in the
javascript ecosystem it works for both
that takes us to rfc 785
test helpers which build on top of these
new first class component templates and
they let us simplify authoring of tests
for typescript users but also for
everyone else
and it makes rendering work the same way
in app code and in test code which
hasn't been true historically
here's what i mean
with first class component templates you
can just use tracked state you can get
rid of using this dot set and this dot
get to do special sauce things in your
tests this dot set doesn't work anything
like it did in app code in the
pre-octane era and in fact it doesn't
work anything like anything an ember
does when you call this dot set in a
template today
in a test today
that triggers the entire app to
re-render immediately nothing does that
so we've gotten rid of that instead you
can
import something like tracked object or
write a class with some tracked state
and
then work exactly like you would in an
app you call render just like you would
today except you pass it a template only
component using first class component
templates and reference the state that's
in your local scope
and then you update that tracked state
just like you would in your app and you
await rerender a new test helper that
works exactly like embers re-rendering
does except
in in app code it's scheduled in test
code you're in control of when it
happens and then you check did that have
the desired effect and spoilers it it
does
the win here is we're composing features
together rather than having to do
special sauce in
tests this all just works and it all
just works for typescript users but it
also all just works for javascript users
for typescript users notice that there's
no monkeying with a test context here in
particular this feels good
now we have rfc 776 typescript
blueprints our goal was to keep our
blueprints up to date always members of
the typescript community in the amber
ecosystem will know that that is not a
thing we have succeeded at historically
we need a single source of truth for our
blueprints because otherwise they just
will get out of sync
and we want this thing we do not to be
something people have to re-implement
over and over again but something that
any ember library or if you're
interested
any non-ember library can use for a
blueprint system
and the how is that we start with
typescript blueprints and if you're a
typescript user we just hand those to
you and if you're a javascript user we
strip out all the types and then hand
those to you
it turns out this is annoyingly
difficult because all the tooling for
these kinds of things in the ember
ecosystem i should say the javascript
ecosystem
speaks in terms of abstract syntax trees
and we need to speak in terms of
concrete syntax trees so to be honest
it's a really clever pile of hacks to
make this work but it does work
and again it's the kind of thing that
means we can move much more quickly
going forward and stay in sync
the net is that you just type dash
typescript when you're generating a
blueprint and it just works you can do
this today on ember 4.4 beta 1 or later
an ember cli beta ember cli 4.3 beta 1
or later you pass the enable typescript
blueprints feature flag and the
typescript flag and when you generate a
component class you get it in typescript
if you pass the typescript flag
we're very excited to see this land
unstable because we're very tired of
trying to keep the component blueprints
up to date
the last key authoring code feature is
rfc 748 the glimmer component signature
type which is designed to let us fully
represent what a component is its
arguments
the
element that it will apply splat
tributes to if any and any blocks that
it yields
and this provides nice hooks both for
documentation tooling and for glint to
be able to type check things
the research we did in this also gave
nice input for other parts of the
ecosystem modifiers and helpers for
example our types already support the
same kinds of things there now
here's what it looks like in practice we
start by defining a signature interface
and applying it as a type parameter to a
component
then within our interface we define what
are the arguments
in this case a name which is a string
and an action set name which takes in an
input event and we'll do something with
it presumably update that name
then we can use those in a type safe way
on the actual component class in the
greeting getter here we derive from the
arg and our input is wired up via the on
modifier to invoke that
one of the nice things here is this kind
of thing also works for js stock so you
can get autocomplete and support that
way in
just a regular javascript component by
writing this kind of thing we cover that
in our docs
we also document the element we're going
to splat tribute onto a div element so
if you try to pass in a modifier that
expects to be on an audio element glint
will say nope sorry you can't do that
and finally we document the blocks that
we yield in this case a header which
receives the greeting and it's a string
if you had a default block you would
just use the name default here
the key is we can now document the full
api surface of a component we can
extract it into docs and glint can type
check it
so that's our updates to code authoring
that's a pretty good set of things and
as i've said throughout all of those
benefit javascript users too which is
one of the reasons i'm so excited about
how we've been approaching this process
the last part of our story is a
documentation update and this one is
far-reaching because remember our goal
was to make typescript a first-class
peer to javascript well that means that
needs to be true in our guides in our
api docs too
we also need to coordinate this with the
rest of our polaris teaching story as we
make all of these features work together
nicely and as we polish up the rest of
the details that we introduced in octane
we need to make updates here this
includes being able to have a toggle
that shows typescript versus javascript
and that probably means different pros
in those places it probably means our
api docs need to know what to do with
generic types when presenting to a
javascript user
there's a lot to figure out there's
designed to be done and so far it isn't
done so we could use your help come work
on it with us we'll mentor and support
you through that the learning team the
amber typescript team and the amber
framework team
that's where we are today where are we
going in the future well number one
we're going to finish what we started
we're going to ship great types with
polaris types have been good in amber up
to today but we're going to we're going
to make them great
second we want to continue collaborating
with the rest of the typescript
ecosystem
many of the things we've done here are
very intentionally not ember specific we
don't want to be siloed and we think
that there's a lot of positive some
outcomes to be had in collaboration
between frameworks between library
authors and so on so please kick the
tires on a bunch of these ideas and
policies and tools and
let us know what does and doesn't work
collaborate with us let's make progress
together
i want to leave you with a vision of the
future what does it look like when we
put all these pieces i've been
describing together all those rfcs we've
written when they're implemented
how will it work so we're just going to
implement a fairly simple component
we'll import component from glimmer
component and then create a class backed
component because i know we're going to
need some state for an audio player this
is the
example i mentioned a few minutes ago
and this audio player will take as its
source an argument so that people can
use this for lots of audio players and
that'll take a url as an argument so
we'll write an interface a signature
which defines that argument url is a
string
i'm thinking about it though maybe
maybe that should be
a
source url so after we apply the
signature let's go ahead and rename it
that's a that's a neat feature if we can
make that work
we'll also specify that we'll splat our
attributes and therefore modifiers onto
that audio element so if someone tries
to pass a modifier that
works only with divs it it won't type
check
now to actually handle play state we're
going to need some tracked state so we
import track from glimmer tracking and
we define an is playing type variable on
this class
and let's not play by default that's
that's not kind
we'll author then a couple buttons and
wire them up to that tracked state
these buttons of type button for good
accessibility
will connect using the on modifier and
when someone clicks it we'll call a
couple methods play and pause
now you might notice the red squiggles
there on on and this dot play in this
dot pause that's because we want those
to type check and in first class
component templates we need to actually
import things like on for them to work
the upside here is that there's no
guessing about what it is we just use
normal module resolution
same thing goes for play and pause we
want glint to tell us these aren't
defined yet and it will
we now use those to update the state of
this dot is playing play sets it to true
and pause sets it to false
and then we need to go ahead and connect
those to the audio element so we'll
write a modifier
modifier currently comes from ember
modifier not at ember modifier or at
glimmer modifier we're working on fixing
that but this is what it'll be like for
the near term future so i wanted to show
you honestly and that modifier will be a
play when something is true it'll take
in an audio element and whether it
should play just a boolean and when it
should play we will call the
element.play method and when it should
pause we'll call the element.pause
method and then we'll wire that up on
our audio element we'll apply the play
when modifier there and if we forget to
pass arguments
well glint will tell us it'll also show
us the signature what are the args that
it allows what is the element it works
on so we pass this study's playing to it
it's pretty nice
i get really excited thinking about that
vision of the future
but that's a trick that's not a vision
of the future that's a vision of the
present all of this works today on the
latest version of glint latest version
of glimmer component and ember modifier
everything i just showed is real
and it works for javascript or
typescript
that's that's pretty exciting if you ask
me it's happening
we're going from good to great
this has been the road to typescript
thank you
you